you wanna bang tonight oh hey can you
say the [ __ ] in your room I'm pretending
like I wasn't frantically cleaning for
the best 15 minutes I tried on something
out before I decided on this one
[ __ ] about wine
I've been wine tasting ones hmm
diverting this nervous energy by looking
at a screen putting the burden choice on
you oh I'm not accepting that
responsibility then that case I will
offer up five or six very diverse
choices to show my intelligence sense of
humor if I go into college comment about
that really popular series everyone's
talking about me in lab yeah but
starting a series yeah there's a lot of
commandment who cares we won't be
watching the movie anyway oh yes I just
want to make out a lot and do other
stuff alright getting ready be nervous
for 20 minutes about when to touch you
and how we decide to sit now we'll
determine a precedent about the rest of
our relationship knowing the doctor
mom's genome in ten minutes
I'll take let's do that no too fussy
Regina not actually scared I just wanted
to touch your leg
commenting on the movie they're starting
overlapping dialogue
I'm eating but I know what you're
actually giving considering other side
baby I'm just kind of talking to talking
like my face hoping you're gonna take a
hit I'm hiding my boner with my elbow
hoping you gonna make a move so I can't
tell if you like me
I mean your cereal